in the name of Robert of the house Baratheon
the first of his name don't look away king of
the Andals in the first father will know if you
do Lord of the Seven Kingdoms and protector of
the realm I Eddard of the House Stark Lord of
Winterfell and warden of the North in the name
of Robert of the house Baratheon the first of his
name king of the Andals and the first men lord of
the Seven Kingdoms and protector of the realm in
the name of Robert of the house Baratheon first
of you know how it goes fill in the damn titles
Eddard of House Stark titles titles to serve as
Lord regent and protector of the realm upon my
death Joffrey of houses Baratheon and Lannister
the first of his name king of the Andals and
the first men lord of the Seven Kingdoms and
protector of the realm Joffrey Baratheon is the
one true heir to the Iron Throne by the grace
of all the gods lord of the Seven Kingdoms and
protector of the realm i Joffrey of the house
Baratheon first of my name the rightful king of
the Andals and the first men lord of the Seven
Kingdoms and protector of the realm I would
name you the hand of the king you will serve
as hand of the King in my stead do you believe
the hand of the king is welcome at all small
council meetings father is handling I was very
happy as hand of the king I named you hand of the
Queen you will be my hand Samwell Tarly of horn
Hill Tywin son of Tytos of House Lannister Lord
of Casterly Rock warden of the West nine years
Syrio Forel was first sword to the Sealord of
Braavos and master of whisperers Robb Lord of
Winterfell Lord of Winterfell and King in the
north Lord of the Seven Kingdoms and protector of
the realm kneeling before the king-beyond-the-wall
which is why I'm naming you new master
of coin master of coin I am the guardian
Lannister and Cersei Lannister the Queen regent
I suppose it is former Queen Regent now this is
Stannis Baratheon the one true king of the Seven
Kingdoms you were the princess Shireen of house
Baratheon and the princess Shireen of house
Baratheon I'm your daughter Ramsay of house
Bolton heir to the dreadfort and Winterfell where
would I find the High Septon no high Sparrow or
whatever bloody fool name he's got Cersei of House
Lannister mother to His grace King Tommen widow
of His grace King Robert the bastard of Robert of
the house Baratheon first of his name king of the
Andals in the first man you are Lord again drew
Baratheon of storms and the lawful son of Robert
Baratheon I am Yara Greyjoy daughter of beylin
Greyjoy king of the Iron Islands I am Tyrion
son of Tywin of Clan Lannister this is Shagga
son of Dolf chieftain of the stone crows timett
son of timett ruler of the burned men chella
daughter of cheyk leader of the black ears my
lord father the Kings hand sends his greetings as
well I am Tyrion Lannister of Casterly Rock master
of coin coins sheep's wool Tywin and I already
determined that I should be the master of ships
long before you in addition to being master of
ships the King has appointed you master of coin
I'm not a child I am the Lady of Winterfell and
I am home I am no Commander of the Nights Watch
Lord Commander I'm Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch born the bastard of Winterfell now the Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch I'm no Commander
of the Nights Watch we named you King in the
north he's killing off now the king in the north
I've been an e I'm not King in the north anymore
talking about the king in the north I'm talking
about the king of the bloody Seven Kingdoms first
of his name king of the Andals and the first men
and Lord of the Seven Kingdoms the one true king
of Westeros Stannis Baratheon I Stannis of the
house Baratheon first of my name rightful king
of the Andals and the first men sentence you to
die I understand this is Stannis of the house
Baratheon king of the Andals and the first men
lord of the Seven Kingdoms and protector of the
realm yea Iron Throne is currently occupied by
Tommen of the house Baratheon king of the Andals
and the first men lord of the Seven Kingdoms
and protector of the realm i Tommen of the house
Baratheon first of my name king of the Andals
and the first men lord of the Seven Kingdoms
so I one of the House Lannister hand of the King
protector of the realm in the name of King Tommen
of the house Baratheon first of his name you're
hereby sentenced to death in the name of Renly
of house Baratheon first of his name rightful
king of the Andals and the first men lord of
the Seven Kingdoms and protector of the realm I
Brienne of Tarth sentence you to die you're the
king of the Andals the Lord of the Seven Kingdoms
the protector of the realm the king is supposed to
be the protector of the realm I am Lord protector
of the vales and I command you to escort me safely
back to the Eyrie I think not first of her name
queen of the Andals and the first men protector of
the Seven Kingdoms this series of House Targaryen
the third of his name the rightful king of the
Andals and the first men and his sister Daenerys
of House Targaryen I am a Khaleesi of the Dothraki
I am the wife of the great Khal and I carry his
son inside me you have the honor of addressing
Daenerys of the House Targaryen Khaleesi of the
riding men and Princess of the Seven Kingdoms
I am Daenerys Stormborn of House Targaryen of the
blood of old Valyria I am the Dragons daughter I
am Daenerys Stormborn of the blood of old Valyria
and I will take what is mine unique a diner as
calm as more enter Gary lndra's in Valyria with
piranha garlic's and noble Lord you are in the
presence of Daenerys Stormborn of House Targaryen
queen of the Andals and the first men Khaleesi of
the great grass sea breaker of chains and mother
of dragons Jim ISA esposa greases messy pleasure
a ESPO Velma Massimo ionizer demmas a necrotic
area 0/0 windows doors auntie marina daria and
roc area vajradhara helper menko and Bosma Holly
C Valmont legatus simonia zat resulted and her
dynasty Vasco Ayala toggery attack maracas
on my other sock Kelly simony Felice Amanda
Amanda Ranieri maitake Holly Samara Vashi job or
severe Barak I'm not the breaker of shades and not
the unburnt and I am certainly not the mother
of giants mother of dragons breaker of chains
and all that to Daenerys Stormborn mother
of dragons breaker of chains you stand in
the presence of Daenerys Stormborn of House
Targaryen rightful heir to the Iron Throne
rightful queen of the Andals and the first men
protector of the Seven Kingdoms the mother of
dragons the Khaleesi of the great grass sea the
unburnt the breaker of chains this is Jon Snow
he's king in the north i Daenerys of House
Targaryen first of my name breaker of chains
and mother of dragons sentence you to die
i Daenerys of House Targaryen first of my
name a breaker of chains and mother of dragons
Daario Valerio valeri @o have brand the broken
first of his name king of the Andals and the
first men lord of the six kingdoms protector
of the realm we appear to be missing a master of
whisperers and a master of laws and a master of
war yes your grace King brand the broken ruler
of the six kingdoms and protector of the realm